Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to "West of Loathing".
Now we just got off the train,
Which means that we got more of this place to explore before we have to head off over there.
There's a ton of this area here that I haven't seen and I don't think that the train ride is gonna be the last of
It but I want to make sure that I get all the skills that I need to get
Before I need to do that so the first thing. I'm gonna do is. I'm gonna go to hellström ranch
I'm gonna farm because number one, I haven't leveled up myself in a while
Hey, that's nice. I got more blood building tonic and orthopedic boots?
Hey
Dr. Scholl's made boots out here in the wild alright
It's made by the same person that was that jogger over there, alright, but either way. This is a good place to farm up some cows
So that's exactly what i'ma do so I'm gonna be right back before I farm up these bad boys alright
So I got a lot of XP I got 2,800 now. I'm gonna up my
Hornswoggle into maximum level. I'm gonna up my
dickering? Do I want dickering? Do I want dickering?
What is quick to the draw? I don't know did I? What do I need?
Oh, duh, I just said I needed to upgrade my normal skills. I-I'm an idiot
Let me get lock-picking just in case and then I need more all of this basically everything of this more shootenanny definitely.
Moxie okay, that's enough of that okay, so that's good so we're gonna go uh
Elsewhere now we got a whole bunch of other stuff. I need to ask Gary is what I need to do because Gary knows
Gary knows stuff about what you're supposed to be doing and go to Frisco for the uagah any other ideas
middle of investigating a missing sh- Oh
How about another saltpeter back to the chef in Dir- oooh
For another house in the desert. Oh, I forgot about that. I had luck oh
Okay, I got to go back to Dirtwater, and I gotta take care of the house-in-the-desert gang
I forgot about them. Oh let's go over to the desert house and finish that off because I totally forgot that was even a thing!
Holy shit, that was so long ago
That wasn't really, it was just long ago, because I accidentally flubber knucked up
But the reason I'm able to do this again is remember, I got to the gun slinger so I'm not
I'm not a whip whopper anymore. I'm not a cow punchy-wunchy
I'm a gun slinger wingy, and I just got to put a lock on this door
Lock them in
Deh, there we go arrest him
F: "Okay, fellas the jig is up."
A muffled voice says: "The law get them boys!" and then,
"Tarnation! We're locked in!"
You hear a chorus of defeated sighs.
Aah, Hornswoggling
hand over your weapons.
F: "I'll tell you what toss out your weapons, and I won't arrest you."
you hear quiet but heated discussion inside eventually a voice says, "All right," and some pistols fall out the window.
Just kidding, I'm still gonna arrest you oh
Those guns would have been amazing as a gunslinger. I could have been throwing guns at my enemies.
"Just kidding, I'm still gonna arrest you."
A voice says, "Aww, dangit."
Oh
dagnabbit
That's the House-in-the-Desert gang, all right. All except for the house, that is. Did it get away?
"What? Was I supposed to.."
"Heh, naw, just messing with you. Here's your reward."
All right? Thank you
I think I got everybody and they're all alive well, I mean
Except for the dead ones, but you know that's fine. Oh, that's so nice.
I took care of them all!
"Oh hey good to see you. You know you've really cleaned up the area- I'm plumb out of bounties for you."
"Does that mean I get to be Sheriff?"
"No, but I guess I'll be marshal."
Okay, marshals now my new middle name. I think I think that's how that works
Either way I gotta go back to the saloon. Man, it's been forever
God I saw spittoon and my heart just lept up into the heavens. I thought for a moment that yes
This is this wonderful moment. I'll be able to have this okay got the saltpeter okay. Here you go okay
Next thing I need is a certain kind of hot pepper
It's called a murder pepper because it's really spicy because it literally has a knife and kills people who ask dumb questions
They grow in the area outside of town you should be able to find one if you just wander around for a while
Okay
Why am I doing this for you? I don't know, but I'll wander I guess all right studelly Lee do ho ah
This must be the south east western murder pepper that feller at the Jewel was looking for okay. All right
There's a narrow region to the west southeast Western okay, all right, then Welli deli. Let's go backy wacky
I supposy wosie into the kitcheny witcheny any I go all right. I got your murder pepper. What do you want?
Nice big one that'll last a while okay
If you're still looking for stuff to do I need someone to go check my mail
I ordered a new saute knife, but I haven't gotten time to fetch it myself. Here's the key to my post office box
Okay, thank you. Why am I fetching your mail for you. I've got better things to do
There's a whole train in fresco that needs to be done
Did oh, but I guess I haven't been here in a while either so fine peel box one one four was a key
Oh wait, what for you?
Why is it? Oh? I found a?
Big I found a bug okay four four one got a saute knife even though you're holding it
You're still pretty sure there's no such thing as a saute knife anyway
It's too thin to use as a weapon so it's not even worth stealing mm-hmm back to the chef also
Four for one well. I know how to
Saute knives all right one one for ah fort reasons ballistic charts
That's the one that blew up the house mmm interesting
And I need some help tracking down some missing mail
How do you mean a mail delivery went missing on bread Wed and I'm hunting it down on behalf of our mayor the local mail
Station has a bunch of route maps that I don't know which one I need hmm
Well that information exactly secret, but I supposed to just give it out either, but deliver go missing is bad news
Oh, I suppose all right. This is once your sayings. Okay, so each map code is a number on it. What the hell
Based on it gives you a cheat sheet for reference find the right map at the Postal Service weigh station, huh?
What that means?
I'm gonna read this this chart is full of details on the precision firing of the deme Culver and artillery cannon
you know what I bet that cannon could blow the vault door open at Alexandria Ranch open if you could figure out a
Way to target it oh
Good idea
Fire the cannon in the poor unsuspecting house that was already fired upon by the cannon oh
Hey, it's you
Thanks for telling me about this place instead of arresting me for shooting me in the head and then arresting me no problem
I'm not really a bounty under any way just looking out for help people well. You sure did help me out
I'll really appreciate the opportunity and things are going pretty well, not a thing yeast monster. Yeah
Yeah, what can I get you? I don't know. What do you got?
Muscle mystic allottee moxie if I could actually eat anything else I would probably do that but you know I think I'm okay, yeah
Cows blood yeah
Years of being stuck in the nose of a cow have done nothing to finish on this thing
I don't know what I'm supposed to do with that, but I don't I don't want to wear it
I don't want to wear it any um anywhere on my body. You're pretty good. Okay. I'm gonna leave this be is anybody else here
Wait it's no one else set up shop yet. What the hell is happening
What I?
Thought I had more. Oh, that's oh man how much have I not done then okay anyway?
I gotta find the next place for me to go which is gonna be I just thought of it
I was just thinking about four treason in that over there long way pretty much across the entire world
Where's jumble neck mine? I want to go to jumble neck mine. Oh, it's on the way apparently ooh. hello
Rocks probably some mind leavings that got piled up here search the rocks you poke around in the rocks
But don't you think of interest I?
Don't know what I was expecting
Hello a sign it says jumble neck mine. What is this meaning? It's just a name are names for things really don't mean anything no
Gary is meaning orange blossom. I'm not sure what to do with this knowledge barrel is full of old grease
I'll take some I'll scoop a handful put in my bag. What disguise said I would
Sass me game what just grab a handful no
I mean what I said
And I want it
frick you
Except for the dust all over everything and the fact that the guy at the desk is ghost this looks like a regular mine Foreman saw
this oh
Okay
standard-issue miner's helmet hanging on it I
Got a miner's out it old calendar stop working work stop. I thought it said that calendar stopped working months ago
I'm an idiot this ghost is busy shuffling the ghost of papers on his desk
Excuse me kid. I'm busy here. I've got a mind to run take a hike okay
This mine is still running. I haven't seen anyone around. We're miners
Kid if you saw anyone up here I would have to fire them for not doing their job
I'm not gonna do that voice how's business? Oh just great hunky freakin dory see their face
This is my happy face
And I'm double excited about answering questions from some random kid that wandered into my office while I'm working
Look at how ecstatic I am it's quite a silver tooth
You've gotten that sarcastic grin made it myself
And I made a few little silver trinkets in my time now go away the calendars out of date. What?
yeah it's like six months old. I like the picture. Okay scram
Do you know you're a ghost do you know you're a pain in the ass? No. I'm serious you see me laughing
Okay
Alright how's biz
Never mind, there's nothing here left for that is he the safe is dirty
But solid looking get away from that the ghostly figure behind the desk growls well
Take a closer look you stooped down to take a closer look at the safe
It's pretty standard every day disable the doubt combination lock hey something wrong with your ears
I told you to get away from there try to open this what why you did come here. Nope running, okay?
See ya dude rolling off into the mine. I guess very nothing interesting over here
Why is there nothing interesting over here? Why do you have to tell me? There's nothing interesting all right?
The elevator is pretty dusty inside and doesn't appear to have maintained for quite a while it does seem functional
But the control lever I've said that weird is chained and padlocked you also know that the shaft is totally silent
He'd expect to hear the rumbling of mine carts and the clanking of pickaxes echoing up from below
But there's nothing all right
He picked the lock removed the chains to get the lever a Yank the elevator shudders as it begins to descend
accompanied by the sound of clanking chains and grinding pulleys
Very quickly it becomes too dark for you to see you pull out your lantern and very slowly the elevator reaches its destination
You pull the door open and peer into the gloooom
alrighty, then that was a lot of
what-have-you for this full of rocks nothing special oh
I get to do the cart things ah
Environmental story tell what old pickaxe what does that even mean?
as the initials H H carved into the handle not much Hogarth you
From the I run giant not much good for mining anymore, but you could still knock someone's head off with it
Good to know I guess it's a headless skeletons
skulless its skulless
Skulllllessss
Okay, looks like there was a cave-in check it out alright. There isn't much to see except for rocks
There's quite a lot of them though, so if you want to look at the rocks this great selection to choose from
Alrighty then
It's like someone forgot their lunch box down here there must have been real hungry by now. I got a paper bag
Whoa, I don't know what to do with that. I got a paper bag though, so that's nice. Hello pull the lever
lever is pulled ah
I know what that is this crate is old dynamite dynamite
gets very dangerous when it ages
But you know better than to try to stop you from taking a stick if you've decided you want one
I have decided officially that I will do that thing that you don't want me to do
Here I go I have decided that I have a none
I don't recommend you do a lot of hopping up and down while you're carrying it unstable stick of dynamite the nitroglycerin
To sweat out this dynamite
Um's crystallize on the outside this makes it extremely dangerous, and you should probably not try to use it in a fight
I mean you also shouldn't be carrying around to your pockets too late for warning. Oh
What'll happen if I hop up and down?
What's the worst could happen oh I?
Wonder. What could happen as I seem to be jacking off this Lantern, oh I don't
The cart is full of rocks. It doesn't seem to be anything particularly special about them
Ah stick that old dynamite in there you wedge in a stick of unstable dynamite into the cart. This can't possibly
Go awry. Oh, I know exactly how possibly it could go all right, so I got a shove it
After a moment your distant clang, so what am I do? I think that other thing was like a spring-loaded launcher
there is also a stick of antique dynamite in there for some reason
Why
How about I pull this lever up bang
oh
It seems like it's gonna require something heavier duty than a can of oil
How about a cooking some grease with my hand or put it in that paper bag?
I just found, a bit of grease can hold in a paper bag, right?
maybe?
Take some yep. I put it in the paper bag
Hopefully this will come in handy
If you have a good reason to be carrying around a paper sandwich bag full of old grease I was like
That's oh
I
Didn't even press use on that it just assumed I wanted to go into the mine sure thing alright anyway
I'm gonna grease this bad boy up. Oh, that's
boink
Grease up that lever you dump a bunch of grease into the mechanism and use the sandwich bag as a sort of
The term goosh it up there in a while, I don't know if I've ever
Sort of goosh it up there
without getting too much of it on your hands pull that lever you yank hard on the lever and it releases the
Mechanisms wound up springs launching the minecart down the track with a terrific Wang
Noise off in the distance you hear a kaboom. Oh
strange about that
What oh look? It's open now. Oh, man
I really could have goofed that if I'd had to go in the other way
And then I would have been trapped down there, I guess
Give the REC minecart a salute in respect for its valor and service
Alright, it's hard to tell at a glance but on closer inspection this guy seems to have died in face down a basement or prayer
pose praying to the pit, maybe it's difficult to say might have just been napping weird
The skeleton seems to be reaching out with that weird statuette reaching out with the statute with the hands having fallen off
It's impossible to tell all right some kind of weird statuette. Okay. I got a weird statuette it is
tarnished and blackened and silver statuette in the shape of some sort of creature
you can't exactly tell what it is specifically or even if it has two legs or four legs or wings or what but it's
Depicted with reverence looking at it makes your stomach feel weird like you're starving
But also full of the point of nausea at the same time
this goes in your off hand and I don't know if I want that in fact
I don't want that. I don't want that at all. It's made of silver and tarnish darkness. Yeah, whatever oh?
You seems pretty deep you've kick a rock into it
But never here the bottom throw something into it
You look through you're packing something that might be good to throw into the bottom this pit you hold up the silver toothed skull
Alas poor a never mind. I'll throw it in the hole. Why not I don't want it. Chuck it
Ro toss the skull into the pit as it falls it yells. I'm coming home
That's a little unsettling
who jumps into a pit and Yells, I'm coming home
Dude I don't even know
What an idea wait take the idol out of your bag? You don't like the way it looks in this dim light
You don't like the way it looks at you and this dim light
Throw it in throw the idol into the page the weird feeling in your stomach fades away although you get a sense of well
it's like if you heard someone chuckle behind you except you didn't hear anything and there isn't anyone behind you ah
So is there someone chuckling behind me or not?
All right ah
The cursed blood goblet good grief. Why are you even carrying this thing around?
I
Don't know. I'll chuck it in the hall pitch the gross thing in the hall good riddance. Hey. It's free XP. Oh
Introductory next Maxis boot could be your first step serves real power, but at what cost throw it in the hall oh
Good good
I can get rid of all my shit the shit that I really shouldn't be carrying ah
The comeback cover blurb says it can teach you how to steal people's blood. That's
throw oh that sounds horrible you toss a bug into the hole
Alright, okay. I think I've tossed all my Garbo in there. That's it's good. Hey if you don't go down that route
You can get a goody goody two-shoes hole to throw in
That wonderful. I maybe I don't know anyway. I don't know if there's any way to get to this oh
He's gone since no one is here. You're free to rummage around in this desk. Let's do it. Oh
I've found some extra grisly
jerkey great just what I wanted all right you stooped down. I'm gonna crack this safe a sack of meat
Mmm this thin and a weird knife
This knife has a thin twisty stiletto blade made of tarnish black silver
It looks wicked sharp, but holding it makes you feel a little uncomfortable
Like someone's whispering your name, but you can't quite hear them also
No one's whispering your name, and they're not standing behind you and there's no one there, and you didn't hear anything
Score I guess the office safe is empty. You're the one who empty did remember no no not at all
I don't remember that at all. I don't know what you're talking about I need another shooting nanny. Eventually, but I'll give that
Later thanks. I don't use deploy snake enough. Oh summons a snake tweet
What good is a briefcase full of snakes if you can't occasionally pull a snake out and tell it what to do
Oh
Frickin love that also. Did I do I have any like books keep forgetting if I actually have any book. What is this one?
Flip through the book most of it uneventful. Oh, okay, alright alright now
I'm on the way. There's been a fun detour, but I gotta go to Fort treason because I got a
Frick okay
Sure, Oh a lightning snake out now a dead snake, okay?
thank you very much for that okay back to forward treason because I got a I got a blow up a
Cellar in a poor beleaguered farm that's already been blown up
Debbie Culver and cannon look closely. It's a fine cannon. Oh
Ball that I have forever you look through the range fire on the cannon
But you can't see any indication of anything you want to shoot at you decide not to waste the ball
I know real bad. I want to shoot at ah oh I want wait if I not
Find it yet oh
Wait unable to spell wait a faint this makes a Woo's
Noises and gestures to its roadside grave marker, which has fallen over for some reason. It's a huge millstone
Oh muscle that back up Jud Milson at
1837 died when a millstone fell over on him oh my gosh those weren't sticks they were oh no, yeah, those are definitely
Sticks okay never mind then was it this one. Oh, maybe I never went near or inspected it
I know I want to blow up the cellar ooh
Books are wrecked, but this cellars here
place a
Targeting flare oh it's a cannonball
investigating the horror
Okay, all right now back to fort treason. Yeah
All right fine anyway back. Okay. Is dead. All right. They were gone now when fort trees in here
We go so if I blast this blast II blue
Light it up
boom if that didn't open the vault door then these grapes are probably sour anyway
Is it a wine cellar is that what you mean by grapes? I don't understand that but okay all right. I'll go
Convenient ladder on that
All right books and books and books
That's
Exactly what I needed
I need oh this book is full of tips and tricks about the ancient art of fixing machines by hitting them really hard
also people in
the face
oh
You quickly memorize the entire book you got a book Burke percussive maintenance Tom to get
Smacking you know Markipier's favorite motto time to get smackin
That's what I'd like to say when you're done reading it you notice that the books spine is cracked
you try to fix it by hiting it really hard, but you end up just smashing the books to powder
Oops Oh
Frick time to get smacking ladies and gentlemen oh
That's what I was looking for you. Got modern snake oiler good. I needed that not the map me dumb EMU
oh, I need a good medicine fan hammer I
Need dat I want to creat it up at high noon noon time to get smacking on the fan hammer. I got fan Amer
Oh, I do need that Oh, that'd be nice
That's real nice
You unload round after round into a nearby cactus just to see how it feels it feels pretty good
It's time to get smackin and no cactus gonna stand in my way unfortunately
A stray spark from under your shot sets the magazine on fire and you're unable to prevent it from being destroyed
You choose the book with the most sensational sounding tile how to cheat at poker cheatin
It's part of the game of poker, but getting caught doing it is still disadvantageous this book purports to turn your cheating into
Sneaky cheat it gives you the dirty poker skill. Oh does it now
Oh does it indeed you quickly memorize the entire book so as to cool
You learn how to cheat at a weird variant of Poker they play in these parts so as to conceal the evidence of your dirty
Dealings you eat. The book. Let's smack up the tables
Let's get to smackin everybody else there this lock case contains a book labeled
Gold metal silver smithing okay alright you make sure artwork and grab the book this book written by expert Dabney
bronze
Detailed advanced techniques and melting silver things and turning them into other silver things grate was way. I'm gonna do this
See you read the book and learn a lot more about silver smithing than you knew before
Alright excellent after you're finished reading it you absent-mindedly drop it into a nearby mailbox and are unable to retrieve it
Happy birthday, mr.. Postman
Congratulations, I guess
All right, rich vain poor vain. This copy of a popular financial advice book from a few years ago
It's rare now because various Crusades to destroy
Every copy of it
Should do you quickly memorize the entire book?
Vainglorious, you know how to get a lot more meat out of meat veins well. It's too bad over
He picked up all the meat veins in the area
Unfortunately the book was so old and crumbly that reading it once caused it to be destroyed so much for literary preservation
Tragic the greatest love poem ever written the dust jacket of this book is missing so I can't tell you who?
Who wrote it?
that doesn't Make any sense
Read it poem is so good. You're afraid to even read it because you might fall in love with the book
Okay, sure yeah, alright, whatever
Whatever sure. Yeah, okay? Anyway god. That was amazing. Oh, man
I just it's so nice every single thing that you see in this game
Every single thing is just dripping with so much funny. I love it alright so anyway. That's all the time
I got for this episode. I've got a lot more stuff to do I need to finish
I keep forgetting that in my
double playthrough there are some things in here that I haven't done before but I do have percussive maintenance now and my
Hornswoggle
N' is up
I just need to find something yarn and worthy so that the lady can knit it and maybe like
Maybe she'll make something for the little kid that wants a toy. I don't know either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you think down the comments below and as always I will see you
In the next video, buh bye